if you need something translated from
one language into another
what resource do you turn to google
translate of course
since it's launched way back in 2006
there have been few translation services
that are as widely used by both language
learners
and non-language learners alike google
translate is so popular in fact that in
2018
google reported that the service
translates approximately
143 billion words every day
but how good is google translate really
is it really the best tool
if you need a quick and accurate
translation hi my name is luca from
lookoutpedal.com and today i'm going to
talk to you about the strengths
and weaknesses of google translate as a
language learning tool
as well as all the ways in which you can
use a service to benefit
your learning so what is the purpose of
google translate really
that much is obvious its purpose is to
use a process called machine learning to
take text that is in one language and
quickly and reliably translate it into
another language
the system is not perfect but in most
cases it delivers
free reasonably accurate translations in
a pinch without having to rely on human
translators
it's simple to use too all you need to
do is type the text in your starting
language
on the left side and then pick your
destination language from the drop down
list
on the right side once you've done that
google instantaneously
serves up the translated text on the
right side text box
quick and easy but how can we as
language learners get the most mileage
out of google translate
i have a few key strategies which i will
share with you right now
one never translate single words this is
more of a recommendation than a strategy
but if you follow it the
quality of the translations you receive
from google translate will be
much much better when you use google
translate
never ever use it to translate single
words behind the scenes of google
translate the program is really a
complex series of machine learning
algorithms and neural networks that have
been trained
to translate words and phrases based on
context
in language learning terms context
refers to the surrounding
environment that a word or phrase finds
itself in
context is what is used to determine
which meaning of a word
is the correct one in a specific
situation even if the word itself has
multiple meanings that's why
for example when i say a phrase like
birds can fly
you know that the word fly is referring
to the verb to fly
rather than the pesky buzzing insect
known as a fly
or even the fly found on a pair of pants
machine translators
need context to understand language just
like humans do
if you type the word fly into google
translate it will have no idea if you're
specifically referring to the verb to
fly
or any of the other possible meanings so
it will just pick one for you
as a result since you most likely do not
understand the language that fly is
being translated into
there's a decent likelihood you'll end
up with an incorrect translation without
even realizing it
so again please remember to always use
multiple word phrases
or sentences when you input language
into google translate it's the only way
to ensure
even a reasonably accurate translation
two
create instant bilingual texts with
audio
although i just spoke about how you
should always make sure to throw at
least
one entire phrase or sentence into
google translate at a time
there's actually nothing stopping you
from translating texts that are much
much larger on its main text page google
translate
allows you to translate 5 000 characters
at a time
and that's more than the amount of
characters you would need to transcribe
everything i've said
in this entire video however if you have
an even larger text to translate you can
turn to google translate's documents tab
which allows you to upload
entire text documents to be translated
why is it useful for google translate to
be able to translate
entire documents at a time because this
means that we can use it to create
bilingual texts with audio all in
a moment's notice how do you do this
first you need a text
in your target language you should
always start with an
authentic target language text so that
you're not learning from incorrect
or inaccurate language when you have
your text you can
type paste or upload it to google
translate and have the system translate
that text
into your mother tongue a few moments
later and voila
you've now got a bilingual version of
your original text in both your target
language
and your native language you can then
use a resource like this to read through
the original
forum version using the translated
version as a guide when you get lost or
want to know the definition of a word
i've been using this process recently in
my danish learning
and it has been amazingly helpful first
i grabbed the subtitles from a video on
my favorite danish youtube channel
called
what the ad yes what the
really stands for what the you know then
i simply copy the text
paste it into google translate and i've
instantly got
an interesting and enjoyable learning
resource there is one problem with
grading bilingual textbook google
translate though
which you may have already thought of
google translates translations
are often decently accurate but not
accurate enough to be considered perfect
or at least
equal to what a human translator would
give you though this
may seem worrisome at first we need to
remember the reason why we're using a
machine translator in the first place to
get a free
and quick translation that's at the very
least comprehensible
the translation into your native
language does not have to be perfect it
has to be good enough for you to
understand the text in your target
language
and in this regard i think that google
translate does a respectable job
especially compared to other translators
and even earlier versions
of google translate itself if you're
still worried about getting as accurate
a translation as possible
there are a few things you can do one
translate simple texts
two translate between closed languages
the more complicated a text is
the more likely google translate will
have a hard time translating it so
as much as you'd like to use the service
to get a quick and free translation of
say dostoyevsky's the brothers karamazov
the end result probably isn't going to
be very useful for you to get as
accurate a translation as possible you
should stick to simple texts
like the ones normally written for the
benefit of say beginner
and intermediate language learners
anything more complex like slang
academic articles
literature and whatnot and the
translations might look
a little bit like gibberish there are
certain linguistic features that can
make it easier for google translate to
give you a reliable
translation between two languages the
most useful of these
is probably syntax which is the set of
rules that govern the order words in a
sentence
languages that share the same order of
elements that is the order
in which grammatical subjects objects
and verbs appear for example
can be easily translated back and forth
languages that are genetically related
usually share the same syntax so if
you're using two languages from the same
language family or
even a larger grouping your ultimate
translation will be much better
in this way it's very easy for google
translate to translate reliably from say
spanish to italian
italian to english english to polish and
so on and so forth
even unrelated languages that have the
same word order
like english and chinese can be
translated more accurately between each
other
but what if you're learning a language
like japanese and
your native languages say english you're
not entirely out of luck
google translates ability to translate
between syntactically different
languages
english japanese italian korean etc has
improved dramatically in recent years
but in general the translations
still remain quite flawed and often
confusing
fortunately though there are a number of
other translation products available
that do a better job at translating
between these specific languages
and many of those have the same features
as google translate
i've left a link in the description box
with more information
now the cool thing about google
translate is that it does not limit
itself to providing just a mere
translation
it also offers a transliteration of
languages with non-latin scripts
and you have a function to read the text
out loud yes
yes it's still a bit robotic and gives
away to weird results but
it overall provides good comprehensible
input in other words it allows you to
transform a completely foreign and alien
text
into something you can read listen to
and understand
three prepare yourself for a target
language conversation
another engaging and smart way to use
google translate is a user to prepare
speaking sessions with your tutor or
language partner when you have scheduled
time for a conversation
be sure to spend at least 20 minutes
beforehand preparing yourself
you can do this by using google
translate to research word and phrases
that will be helpful in your upcoming
conversation let's assume that you and
your tutor or language partner do not
have a conversation topic chosen in
advance
as a result you can decide to talk about
any topic under the sun
i've always found that it's easiest and
most motivating to talk about topics
that we care
about topics that motivate us and topics
that interest us
that make us tick so to speak so pick a
topic that you're really passionate
about
and then imagine the kinds of things you
can talk about when you bring that up in
conversation you don't have to do this
in your target language just yet
just imagine what a conversation on your
chosen topic could look like
then try to simulate the conversation in
your target language
you can even play the role of your
partner as well if you'd like
as you do this you realize that there
are things that you want to say in your
target language
that you don't actually know how to say
no worries that's what we need google
translate for
whenever you find that there's something
in your simulated conversation that you
want to say
but can't simply throw it into google
translate
and write down the result then keep your
list of unknown phrases with you and try
to use them when you actually
meet with your speaking partner that's
what i do every time i have a
conversation with my hungarian tutor
for example i often love learning about
astronomy cosmology and space travel
so whenever i learn a new language this
is a topic i often try to talk about in
that language
so one day last year i was meeting with
my hunger and tutor and decided to talk
about
the moon landing that's not an easy
topic as you can imagine
there were all sorts of words and
phrases that i would need to learn
but did not yet know so i acted out my
conversation alone
and then turned to google translate i
typed in phrases like
the lunar module finally landed the
astronauts were tired
men walked on the moon and so on and so
forth notice how i don't put single
words and instead put phrases or short
sentences
remember the rule no single words ever
once i had my translated phrases i was
able to put them to use effectively when
talking to my hungarian tutor even
though this technique often does
go according to plan it's useful to
remember that conversations are often
predictable sometimes your conversation
will take an unforeseen
turn and you'll realize that there's a
phrase or two that you need but
don't know how to say in your target
language again no need to worry
as already mentioned google translate is
super fast so you can always just
open it up on your computer or phone and
get a quick translation on the spot
since your tutor or language partner is
with you you can always get
immediate feedback on the correctness of
the translated phrase
or sentence now with that piece of
advice you might be worried that using
google translate during a conversation
is like cheating on an academic exam
trust me it's nothing of the sort
if you use google translate in this way
you're using it to facilitate
conversation rather than allowing
yourself to get stuck in those awkward
moments when
and where you're desperately trying to
think of a word you need but
it won't come seriously if you're
worried about this
i recommend that you actually tell your
partner or tutor upfront that you will
be using google translate for quick
translation
there is freedom in truth and no shame
in using technology
to facilitate communication and help you
speak better remember
a conversation in most cases is not a
level test
or a performance to be critiqued it is a
connection
that benefits both people the easier it
naturally flows
so there you have it these are just
three ways in which you can use google
translate
to wrap it all up for language learning
google translate is neither a blessing
nor occurs rather it is just a tool that
when used correctly can
help you quickly find decent quality
translations between two languages
you can use it to create bilingual
comprehensible texts to
prepare conversations and use it on the
fly
to help you find words and expressions
you don't know
or still can't use all in all i think
google translate is a great tool
it's free it's easy to use and intuitive
in most situations
it does have its limitations of course
especially for
certain combinations of languages but
the overall quality of the translations
are constantly
improving in any case i think it's best
used by
beginner or low intermediate learners
and with combinations of languages that
share
a similar syntax now how do you use
google translate
have you always used it in the same way
or has your use of it changed over time
let me know in the comments below also
if you enjoyed the video
be sure to like subscribe and hit the
bell to be notified whenever i publish
another video on this channel
and as always thanks for watching
you